my name is Bradley a fanner I am a
private investigator from Modesto
California I'm investigator Maki Kodaka
I specialize in criminal defense and
surveillance I'm investigator Tim Helton
from Tim Helton investigations I never
played clue as a kid and this is going
to be a unique opportunity
I say what better way to show Who the
world's greatest investigator is than
friendly game of Clue
I want to suggest that this crime was
committed in the study by mrs. white
with the lead pipe I suggest it was in
the kitchen by Miss peacock with the
candles I'm gonna make a suggestion that
it is Miss Scarlet in the kitchen with a
wrench you should be taking good notes
market I always say community broadly
it's investigators most important tool
clue should have DNA these days and
fingerprints are there any surveillance
cameras at any of these rooms a crime
was committed by Colonel Mustard in the
hall with a lead pipe I think you're
ready time to make an accusation an
accusation don't pressure me I think it
was done in the ballroom by Colonel
Mustard who with a wrench
sounds like your mo to me I just did
some great process of elimination that
you guys didn't see I think this crime
was committed by Colonel Mustard with a
knife this is getting tense
can't we ping everybody's cell phone
like rubra see where they were at why
are you looking at my doesn't get some
clues here he's trying to intimidate you
with this love you need to obtain that
information legally sir to limit how
many suggestions you can a people you
have to that's the key to solving a
murder though it's asking a lot of
questions right when I was a much
younger guy and got set up they
pretended my training officer got killed
with a pipe how many murders have you
seen committed with a candlestick in
your career then none then I wonder why
there isn't a character in this game
that's trying to feed us false
information investigators I'm ready to
make an accusation
I believe this murder was committed by
Colonel Mustard with the lead pipe in
the library you out come out
alright investigators I think I'm ready
to make an accusation I believe it was
mustard I'm really upset because I know
Tim cheated my excellent investigative
skills had no bearing on this game
whatsoever there is a mirror right
behind me and I know he was looking
through the reflection and go figure he
murdered me too I mean if this was real
life my my reputation just went out the
window well I feel pretty good about it
I'm gonna miss Brad I'm sorry I just met
Maki today but that's the way things go
[Music]
it's just so sad what's happening over
there oh yeah you don't know the half of
it
[Music]